Des images impressionnantes.
Des silos du port de Beyrouth
s'effondrent en plein
après-midi, laissant place à
un important nuage de fumée et
de poussière.
Des hélicoptères de l'armée
survolent aussitôt le secteurpou
et limiter les dégats.
Des incendies faisaient rage
dans ces silos à grains depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines,
causés, selon les autorités,
par la fermentation des stocksds
aux fortes températures.
Ce nouvel incident survient
presque deux ans, jour pour
jour, après l'explosion
du 4 août 2020 dans le port
de la capitale libanaise.
Les énormes quantités de nitrate
d'ammonium qui ont exploséont c,
fait plus de 200 morts et
6500 blessés. Les traumatismes
sont toujours bien présents.
"Je faisais des courses lorsquee
j'ai vu s'effondrer de gros
morceux. J'ai ressenti le même
sentiment que lors de
l'explosion de 2020, dit-il.
Les mêmes souvenirs."
Les autorités croient que
d'autres effondrements
pourraient se produire
incessamment. Mais cette mise en
garde ne date pas d'aujourd'hui,
note cetnote cetnote cetnote ce.
- Comme toujours, au Liban,
les gens mettent en garde,
mais rien n'est fait.
- L'enquête sur les causes
du drame de 2020 est suspendue
depuis des mois en raison de
tractations politiques.
Les familles des victimes et
des ONG accusent notamment
les autorités de négligeance
criminelle et de corruption.
SOFIA AMARA, collaboratrice
spéciale à Beyro
- La seule manière de
neutraliser ces silos,
c'était de les détruire.
Or, les familles des victimes
s'y opposaient absolument parce
que pour elles, c'est le témoin
du calvaire de leurs familles.
- Ce Beyrouthin y voit
d'ailleurs une autrs une autrs e
politique.
"Tout ceci est certainement
intentionnel, dit-il,
pour effacer les traces de
ce qu'ils ont fait, toute trace
de cette explosion du 4 août."
Certaines parties des silos
contiennent toujours quelque300à
en raison d'un danger
d'effondrement,
s autorités.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,
Radio-Canada, Mon